that was a really intense conversation
you guys uh just about so much let's
tone it down a little bit and talk about
how the russian state tv has said the
ukraine invasion has already escalated
into world war three
viewers were told to recognize that
russia is now fighting against nato
infrastructure if not nato itself okay i
don't i'm i'm honestly really tired
about ukraine
world war iii blah blah blah
i i was working on my main segment for
uh my tim cass channel
and originally i was like i guess we'll
talk about this because you know the
west is supplying weapons to the
ukrainians they did sink the russian
flagship the moskva and now they're
saying it's world war three because
western forces are basically supplying
ukrainians and then i was like i'm
talking about elon musk because
i'm just kind of sick of talking about
this
and the bigger issue here i don't think
is the is the day-to-day play-by-play of
the war and the stupid points being made
by pundits but
the fourth turning
so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna use
that to launch back to you know i think
maybe the first time we had you on ben
we were talking about the fourth turning
and how we didn't know what it was going
to be maybe war with china and now it
looks like it's going to be war with
russia are brett are you familiar with
what the fourth turning is no not at all
all right do you want to give us the
elevator pitch ben i will and first i'd
like to say that you wanted to tone it
down into world war three i love that
yeah
i just wanted to make sure the audience
also understands that yeah um so neil
howe and william strauss wrote a book
back
published in 1997 i think they
researched it for 10 years
and it's called the fourth turning and
in 97 when this book came out it's
laying out like sometime around well
basically there are seasons and it takes
about 80 to 90 years so every 80 to 90
years there seems to be a crisis period
so you go back it was world war ii great
depression back before that it was civil
war back before that revolutionary war
you could even trace it back before that
in england with the glorious revolution
and a little bit further back
but basically it's this idea that
there's a um after a crisis period
there's a high
and there's then there's an awakening
which would be the 60s 70s that kind of
culture and then there's an unraveling
which is like i always get into the
music that that shows you what the
culture is like the nirvana sound garden
this like it's okay not to pretend like
everything's great girls girls girls no
we're going to talk about like something
is coming apart so anyway they said by
2005 give or take three years there's
going to be an inciting incident and
that inciting incident will likely be
economic and it will
steamroll into many other things they
mentioned bill gates and vaccine agendas
in in one sentence they said the the
possibility for a um a pandemic
they said the possibility for rural
gangs and um
or urban gangs and rural um militias you
know at each other's throats i think blm
and proud boys and that kind of stuff
all the way to um weapons of mass
destruction or the the thought of
weapons of mass destruction a plane
being hijacked by terrorists and um and
then it all come potentially comes back
on
the country itself as a false flag
attack and i'm just like in 97 like all
most of these things come so so the the
gist is aside from their you know the
predictions they put out which we're
seeing to a certain degree it's that the
fourth turning is this the fourth season
the 20 the fourth generation or 20-year
period
where some great catastrophe happens
and so we're we're supposed to be in
that right now and the culmination is
what it ends 2028 but it should be
culminating 2026 like the peak the
climax that the crescendo which is the
250-year uh birthday of the us
who is that person who said uh i forget
what his name is but he says empires
only last 250 years that's his life
expectancy and in every fourth turning
the most advanced weapons of war will be
used so the last one you see obviously
nagasaki hiroshima
this time around we were we were talking
last time like what do you think it
would be you think it would be bigger
bombs or more death and destruction and
you said something that i thought was
very on point which was like the mind
it's it's a psychological warfare
and and what we're talking about now
and and then dovetailing into the
metaverse i think you know it's that and
also this technology that potentially
even frequency wise can modulate
hormones
i mean i
i think it's already being used and i
would say that there's a lot of people
who say that you know fourth turning is
only like 75 to 80 percent correct and
i'm like they wrote it in 97 if they
were 50 correct that's incredible right
so
so is it uh and hold on uh
joe biden remember do you you did that
thing where he was talking about the new
world order yeah he says in that
every three to four generations there's
this big i forget the exact words first
he said something funny
i was in what do you say yes a high
security meeting military military guy
told me this and it's like joe please
don't leave stop
you know clearance information
but what he was saying was that a
high-ranking military officer told him
that effectively the strassau
generational theory was correct or at
least
alluded to this idea
joe biden says
60 60 million people died or whatever
and so he says there's gonna there's
gonna be a new world order and he's
referring to the liberal liberal world
order and what they're saying is it's
changing now with this coming conflict
and there's gonna be a new one and we
have to lead it
so it sounds like even joe biden thinks
things are gonna escalate but let me
revise my previous position
and entertain a possibility here
uh
in the fourth turning the most powerful
weapons are used and and we talked about
this maybe it's social media the
psychological manipulation and control
of population if you can get a pop a
country
to worship you without firing a single
bullet of course you would it's cheaper
it's faster it's easier it's safer right
you uh it's more efficient you save
resources you don't take out power
plants you might need in the future
but now we're seeing in russia zielinski
just he keeps screaming bloody murder
he's he's warning now that russia will
use nuclear weapons i gotta be honest
when he came out and was like oh no the
nuclear power plant and the
international nuclear committee whatever
this group was was like oh no
everything's fine they weren't going
after the reactors i'm like this guy i
get it he's desperate for help ukraine
is being beaten down russia is is firing
missiles all that stuff
but then when he comes out and says
they're going to use nukes i go oh
really and then i see on russian tv
they're like nato is supplying weapons
to ukrainians and they sank our flagship
if the russians believe the sinking of
their black sea flagship was nato and
not ukraine which they probably do
because let's be real ukraine is said to
be one of the only countries or the only
country to become poorer since the fall
of the soviet union
they have the capability to sink a
russian flagship russia denies it at
first they claim credit if russia really
does believe that nato is supplying
forces
nato is attacking them why wouldn't
russia say
nukes
uh hitler that's why he declared war on
the united states because they were
running weapons to britain before the
when britain was at war with germany
before the united states germany never
gone toward think about hitler was a
genocidal maniac putin doesn't seem like
it he just seems like he wants the
territory so i don't think he's gonna go
to world war i don't think he's gonna
declare war on nato but i mean if they
keep blowing up russian ships with nato
weapons
what choice does russia have at that
point i mean you could always surrender
they could always surrender
or call a white piece and just end it
what if putin was like
you know
i don't want the world to end
so i quit
and then like they just it's happened
many times in the past
if you fight a war to a stalemate on
both sides of side it's called a white
piece you just it's over and there's no
no victory terms no one wins no one
loses you brought up hitler have you
heard of tim snyder
he writes about like ukraine and
hitler's eastern front more than
hitler's western front and he he's fully
convinced that and i think he's written
seven books on it that ukraine
was
hitler's eastern aim and maybe the whole
aim
um he like the the whole colonization
that was happening at that time they
were a little behind potentially world
war one i'm not as advanced as tim
snyder was but he said that his eyes
were fixed on ukraine
and so like that's that's an interesting
tidbit of history there in ukraine and
also like i don't want to side rail it
but there's this is a book by yuri
shilov ancient history of arata ukraine
20 000
bc to 1000 ce so it goes through a lot
of history the ancient history of
ukraine is incredible and a lot of the
spots where there are these burial
mounds with like 63 caves underneath and
petroglyphs that seem to be
proto-sumerian
so prior to gobekli tepi the earliest
civilization where agriculture comes
from seems to be right in this area and
i mean there's there's something really
interesting about like the ancient
ancient history of ukraine that also
where the symbol of
the um the swastika and some even say
the um the yin yang symbol may have
originated there that the the russians
the belarusians the slavs the aryans
have an origin primarily in ukraine
so
some kind of sacred land that it's like
a land bridge that's for sure it's flat
and it connects asia and europe a lot of
their most sacred spots were all along
the um dinipro uh river and also there's
cortis island which is in the dinipro
and tibetan monks claim their origin to
be there in ukraine and supposedly even
have documentation to prove it on this
book but the thing is is yuri shilov an
anatoli confession leading
archaeologists and sumerologists you
can't find anything in english except
this book
and i've tried to get in touch with him
i've tried to get in touch with tim and
uh heather lee hooker that have
translated some of the work
nowhere to be found yeah the black sea
uh port makes it such an amazing piece
of land to control strategically you can
get into basically the the oceans and
you can get all over the continent just
a quick thing on the black sea
as i was researching a lot of this i
find putin's face everywhere and all
these ancient sites he goes into this
submersible check out um putin in a
submersible in the black sea going down
to the bottom of the black sea to find
an ancient ship
interesting
and there's
you'll see some of the images where oh
yeah
oh what's this dude it's happening you
know if he wants to swear
what if what if vladimir putin was
actually just like nick cage and
national treasure
and they're trying to frame him because
he's going to uncover the secrets of
europe i did not want this power i must
free them yeah all the way out to the
ural mountains all these ancient sites
that apparently uh belong to the same
core civilization prior to the sumerians
putin was everywhere i found pictures
everywhere visiting these ancient sites
so i don't know what it means i'm just
throwing it out there because it's food
for thought
well i mean look hitler believed in a
lot of occult crazy stuff too
and putin could be motivated by
weird stuff
no idea yeah for sure the uh israeli i
mean that's a holy land it's all about
that area and not maybe not all about it
but a big part of it is
they wanted to be in the area where
jesus was so a lot of times i mean it's
culturally there's an importance to
people about being in a specific area
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time